al'approche de la rentrée au travail à
l'école la santé publique du québec ne
s'en cache pas concil cas de virus nous
a surpris plusieurs fois des variantes
du virus de lakovic 19 pourrait à
nouveau perturber la vie des québécois
cela dit avec le temps des chercheurs
chez moderna aux mises au point une
version améliorée de leur vaccin qui
cible spécifiquement le variant au
micron le variant le plus répandu
d'europe
les autorités britanniques l'ont
approuvé aujourd'hui sur leur territoire
et des pourparlers ont déjà lieu depuis
le 30 juin entre moderna et santé canada
afin que le vaccin façon d'entrer ici au
pays dans une déclaration écrite la
pharmaceutique américaine affirme que
s'il est autorisé nous travaillerons
avec les autorités locales pour le
rendre accessible le plus rapidement
possible s'il est approuvé par les
instances officielles web cela j'aurais
pris aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faudrait
d'abord que je lis beaucoup d'articles
d'abord sur ça parce que
je vais pas me piquer si c'est parce
qu'on met dans la bouche de record mais
si ça permet de nous protéger puis de le
gardeur centre et moi ma famille c'est
sûr fait important à souligner le
premier vaccin de moderna continue
d'offrir une protection contre les
formes sévères de la maladie la version
2.0 du vaccin donnerait donc une
couverture immunitaire plus ciblées
selon le docteur karl weiss il faut les
voir comme finalement une marque
automobile qui arrive avec un modèle
amélioré d'année en année donc avec les
années on gagne en expérience on est
capable d'avoir des vaccins qui sont
plus polyvalents et qui vont donner une
couverture immunitaire peut être plus
ciblés je vous dirai à long terme alors
qu'on parle de plus en plus d'une
huitième vague à l'automne le premier
ministre françois legault donnera une
conférence de presse mardi pour inciter
les québécois à recevoir leur dose de
rappel ici gabriel proulx radio canada
montréal